now you guys have talked about you're  walking away from the Avengers but and I  read someone when you thought Energon  snow I'm gonna be cool about this this  is going to be you know it's just a  chapter in my life I'm fine  yeah well I yeah I died maybe you've  you've had this when you get people come  up to you in the street and they say you  John snow and you can like not  technically I'm not John snow no let's  go with it I'm John but I kind of waited  I really really had waited to say the  words not anymore  like in a really stoic kind of cool way  like the first person I go no anymore  what really happened was I left set and  I was very emotional and this poor kid  came up to the airport and when you John  snow no  [Applause]  walked away don't ask he doesn't like it  [Music]